how's it going BR my name
is welcome to a new let's play this one
is called condemn criminal or agents now
every time oh look that bir looks pretty
happy hey how you doing there he got a
pretty big thing there that sound really
pring all right uh crime rate increased
recording similar increas deadly intent
which is 35
8% all right every time I start your
let's play oh godam what the hell is
going
on what is
this oh you don't look
nice Sega of America anyway I'm playing
this game now I know everyone is like
hey you should play this game and this
game but now we're playing this game
that's kind of what I wanted to say
there before but anyway it's a monolith
production game original concept by
Jason H Nathan Hendrick
oh what the hell creepy
[Music]
images all right I didn't know about oh
what the [__] hey calm down bro whoa
what
the um all right I guess that's
us oh we're like a criminal detective
guy or
whatever I don't know does that go
through his ear holy [__] who what don't
scare
me all right fine don't smash my window
boy I think it's a boy not sure he could
be wearing panties that automatically
makes him a man people are scared we
need to get this one follow me bodies
this way all right fine I follow the F
whoa my sensitivity hey I can see my
feet yeah yeah spin that [__] to get
under thee s is out of
control sorry I just this is way too
much
sense controls I guess
Mouse better go down there boy it's
still [__] out of control but
whatever duck under I did it hey come on
let's go bod's rotten as we speak
whatever you say man but the trollman on
duty said there was a mannequin involved
just like the Matchmaker no oh not the
mannequins anything but the mannequins
escape to review object Ives cool follow
the the Iron Man doing that right now
can't you see sup po how you doing don't
tell oh that a weapon they always to
kill such maggot infested dumps that's a
good can't they pick a nice spot without
addicts and gang members for
once Barrel what are you doing there
Barrel don't think I don't see you very
well point there policeman Jesus nearly
shot the bastard where did you sho that
b with fire why do I care I better pay
attention to this man Ah that's a nice
door God D It's kind of creepy I don't
like I don't know about this place man
feel like someone is watching me I see
you oh sorry
hello can I have one of those
flashlights
please all right you go first I'll just
guard this
Corridor oh [__] he's flash I told you
bro told her to bring extra batteries
but no car broke my light oh yeah sure
it's my fault look at that [__] look at
that you scared
now [__] what's going on in here can I
run or
what cool dead bird how you doing I can
pick it
up birds collect all right you collect
dead birds iide a big thing for dead
birds I don't know why they are pretty
cool I usually dance with them
especially during
christmased Becker here FBI on the scene
over and out what's going on Becker
what's going on Beck Thomas this is
Officer Becka Bea found the body on
patrol look at my feed Becker oh yeah
that's right you better step
aside that's right Becker Becker guard
this place with whatever you have and
I'll be right back oh God damn it look
at that butt the hell is going on
here the [__] is this
[__] whoa they have no
faces
bastard Thomas up hello Thomas this is
Lieutenant Rosa I'm your lab tech again
on this one our wireless data transfer
system enables you to inv collect the
CRI and transmit it to me for analysis
when I have results I'll contact you via
your cell phone the hell all right let's
get to work
let's start by determining the cause of
death when your inss tell you evidence
is nearby prepare a forensic tool the
system will select the correct tool for
you so don't worry about that all right
I guess we got to do detective
[__] press the ready tool to use the
detection
tool light on the corpse and find the
trauma Point it'll a bright purple I'll
just scan this get man's nipples and
then we'll be done with this place I'm
just kidding all right let's
scan the corse
maybe ah there we go cool find
something ooh we got camera who hey I'm
pretty late to this [__] just a
sec strangled by hand God damn look at
her Mor creep as [__] bruise intensity
indicates the Killer's right-handed and
missing the index finger on that hand ah
nice noce there must be something more
something we're not seeing like it her
hair
oh what is
this what is he doing is he eating her
face oh [__] that [__] oh it's just
caring it out cool
oh
cool hell is going on
here run over the criene laser laser
show a bright green hey Becca get the
lights the agent's laser works better no
no no no no I prefer the lights on
please light on [__] me what the hell is
that all right I guess I got a no that's
not right I like her face it's
like oh okay here it
is so we got something here I
think
uh oh I got to focus the shed there we
go there we there we there gorgeous now
smile for the camera please I said smile
from the cameraing image all right there
we go up Carl how you doing the same
Mark what do you think about this
situation exact same Mo as the others
it's the work of a guy we've been
calling the Matchmaker kills young women
violently poses them in Grizzly tap low
with meale department store mannequins
mannequin always slightly disfigured by
a mark on the
face seriously [__] [__] going on any
luck in the mug book searches I bet the
killer has the same
Mark no luck so far God damn it well you
know some sometimes no smoking at a
crime scene that's right Becker I told
you m oh well someone was oh no I don't
know magusta who's smoking we're dying
here I'm dying here it's coming from
don't scare me okay cool sup Becker you
stay there I'm watching you Becker
whoa beer did you do that [__] was he
him super confused right now dang it I
can smell the cigarette smoke oh hell
no hell no you don't smoke on my watch
[__] what's going on here he's right
above us really call for backup now this
is Officer Becker we need backup
immediately start potential homicide
suspect still in building officers are
on their way ta 10 minutes copy that
Becker and I will head up the fire
escape God damn it
ah no I'll go with Becca please okay now
he's playing with us change of plans
Becca secure that door Thomas check out
the building and get these lights back
on Rog you that man policeman I can't
tell if it's like in the middle of the
night or day or whatever it's really
weird Becker you're so screwed I'm sorry
look at that [__] he doesn't know what
all clear agent it's like I'll just look
over here and make sure it's okay sooner
we finish up here the better let's
go oh
no all right we are back and I'm kind of
creeped out to be honest can't move whoa
whoa what's that who's there I totally
saw something I know you're down here
press mouth to fire again federal agent
come out peacefully or I will use
Force
[__] that's right you don't swear to me
boy he came with me with the
plank everyone side oh yes the city's
full of them now Thomas addicts vagrants
psychotic individuals terribly bad they
come in all kinds really mostly violent
this glad is not naked careful I am
careful what is this can I use
this God damn it I swear I didn't want
Mr CH what are you doing out there God
damn this [__] what whoa are you okay
sir I don't want to really help you you
can kick anyy are you okay are you okay
I don't want to I don't know what to do
die you oh
[__] oh I'm so sorry that was a misclick
I try to use my health potion on there
I'm going to love the kick I can tell
already all right let's go up and
investigate press R to re check ammo
okay got seven bullets bringing [__]
let me down and found my way use vely
use wisely he said I don't know about
that hello are we good we
good anyone in here FBI
[__]
no is this [__] going on here I don't
like this at
all whoa whoa
B what are you doing here huh oh whoa oh
it opens by shooting it cool he listens
to violence at least that's the kind of
I
like huh guess we're clear
whoa who did that boxes just don't fall
automatically
hello back stand back stand back
sir I see you it's obvious your hand is
sticking out you can come out now hello
don't make me hey oh I shot you don't
make me do it again please don't make me
do all right bye that's right FBI
[__] that's how I roll that's
all let's go over here goddamn creepy
setting is anyone in
here hello use to Sprint that's how you
kick doesn't really say how to sprint
I'll rebind the controls in next episode
who is he doing stupid [__] it's not
supposed to run inside
Corridor all right come out wherever all
right you are so screwed he's so
screwed you probably can't see me there
we go you are screwed whoa whoa whoa
whoa come down
everyone they making lava on top of the
floor oh I'm sprinting this is sprinting
apparently all right cool I didn't see
why did that door close by
itself all right
we're actually going to go in here
tomorrow so like video If you enjoyed
subscribe to BR today and I'll see you
in next episode of K hopefully I don't
know if you like this or not but that's
pretty much
it sh
activate come here come here come here
all right stupid hey hey I [__] your
mama last
night oh that's right I did it and she
liked it